tonight on the new reality protesting
during a pandemic people coming together
to address a major issue that we haven't
counted out which is anti black racism
racism on the rise people started
questioning was it safe to approach me
anymore just because of my age and
background the coming cash crunch a
health crisis triggers an economic
crisis that likely is going to trigger
an insolvency crisis the cost of
disposable protective gear plate
unfortunetely it's another plastic plate
and how to plan a summer vacation if
you're planning to go further afield
call where you're wanting to go and make
sure that they are open
[Music]
hello I'm Donna Friesen after months of
being told to stay inside to keep our
distance from other people now we're
watching hundreds of thousands of people
gather on the streets to protest police
brutality and racial injustice making an
already deadly situation more complex
these protests the outrage the calls for
justice would be extraordinary at any
point in American history that they're
happening in the middle of a pandemic in
a country that has the most cases and
the most deaths from kovat 19 makes this
moment exceptional it's never happened
before the spread of an invisible virus
and the very visible death of an unarmed
black man pinned to the ground for
almost nine minutes by a white police
officer has led to an intersection of
two of the biggest challenges our
society has faced health care workers
who were cheered on for their courage
now cheering on protesters who demand
that black lives matter a public health
crisis that's killing people converging
with racial inequality that's killing
people too
black Americans make up roughly 13% of
the population yet available data shows
they account for close to 25 percent of
overall Kovan 19 deaths in the US and in
some counties close to 60% how does that
compare with Canada no one knows
governments here don't collect Govan 19
data based on race and socio-economic
background that is starting to change
because what doesn't get measured
doesn't get addressed there's a gap in
data collection that advocates say could
paint a more fulsome picture of
disparities in Canada and allow for
evidence based decisions on how to shape
future policy that remedies in justices
with me to explore this further is dr.
Annie no room she's a family doctor a
public health and preventive medicine
specialist she's the associate program
director of the public health and
preventive medicine residency program at
the University of Toronto dr. Norman
thanks for speaking with us today
let me ask you first as a public health
specialist when you see all of these
people out on the streets in close
contact in the middle of a pandemic
knowing the novel coronavirus has not
gone away how much does it concern you I
think the fact that people are willing
to go out and speak about human rights
issues even though that they know that
there is a cove in 19 pandemic but they
feel that passionately about it I think
Italy moves me in fact I think overall
is the public health position I can say
that it is important as you know dr.
Teresa Tam and others said to wear
personal protective equipment so wearing
a mask using sanitizer but what I see as
a black woman and physician is people
coming together to address a major issue
that we have in Canada which is anti
black racism which is in fact been
contributing to worse health outcomes
for black people for century an anti
black racism traces back to our history
of slavery of having segregation here
but also just a series of issues around
community injustice Canada is not the
United States we do have a different
history here we like to pride ourselves
on tolerance and diversity as a black
woman and a black physician explain to
us your experience your lived experience
in this country and working as a doctor
in this country but my lived experience
and born and raised in Montreal so
that's where I'm originally from living
in Toronto now as a child I experienced
racism you know in the schoolyard being
called the n-word and things like that
but what I think was most painful is
where teachers made assumptions about my
intelligence at a very young age and I
saw it happen you know time and time
again to my classmate so that's what I
grew up seeing and then becoming
position and then looking at the data
from 1996 to 2006 in Montreal a black
person with a graduate degree had pretty
much the same unemployed
rate as a non black pencil draw bet I
live that I saw the people who went and
got in education did everything that
they needed to do to advance and live
that Canadian dream and be denied
opportunities and I saw the impact that
it had on my peers on young people
seeing you know our parents are telling
us to go to school but they're not
getting the opportunities and so you
know now when I look at the research and
the data and I see how across so many
factors that health whether it's income
or it's education or it's our labor
force that people of African descent are
denied opportunities really just based
on the color verse in even despite
education what is really painful is that
the United Nations lied that in Canada
institutionalized anti black racism is
an issue here they flagged that in 2017
so it's not just my opinion it has
actually been demonstrated to research
who report and even with the United
Nations expressing their great concern
for people of African descent here in
Canada so when you hear people say that
there is no systemic racism in Canada
what do you think when you hear that
well I think it's akin to where you
might have people who are of a dominant
group so let's say men think they don't
think there is any sexism when you're a
part of the group that is discriminated
against you are most likely to know
where there is discrimination I think in
Canada we have that denial we aspire to
that dream of you know a multicultural
society where everybody has equal
opportunity and I think it would be
beautiful if we get there I think we all
aspire to that but we have to face the
fact that we are not there so we can
take the right steps to get there you're
president of the black physicians of
Ontario you also train
public health officials what's the
biggest misperception among the public
and public officials about the
connection between background racial
background ethnic background and health
outcomes I think there are a few but I
think that one of the
biggest ones that exist in medicine is
assuming that race and genetics are tied
together so that where you do see
differences between race so let they
rate some hypertension
one would it presume that it's due to
and to genetic differences but in fact
we know that there's no genetic or
biological differences between the races
race is a social construct that is used
to create social barriers and stressors
that then impact health so the concept
of race is only real insofar that we as
a society categorize people that way and
treat people based on that but it is not
biological let's talk about race face
data we don't collect it in Canada
though some cities are now starting to
do that you believe it is vital can you
explain why we're cold in nineteen but
even card to Cove in nineteen to be able
to take the appropriate measures to
address health issues you need a clear
picture of what's going on at a
population level so that's kind of
standard public health approach so
that's why we collect information on
cross gender or where people live
sometimes it's their postal code just to
get a sense of you know risk factors
things that make people more vulnerable
the other reason that you want to
collect the data is that if you do have
an intervention if you put resources
towards prevention or addressing an
issue you want to know that it is
actually improved and is working on the
other hand for a lot of racialized and
including indigenous communities there
is a certain amount of mistrust with
having you know government leaders
collect this information and interpret
it in a way that can sting the thais
communities so we know that in Canada
lots of data has been collected on
indigenous communities and used to
stigmatize them we know that in the
United States lots of data has been used
in describing african-american
communities and used to stigmatize and
pathologize that to make it seem like
something is wrong with that community
instead of something's wrong with the
society that put the community in that
situation that's why there's been a
hesitancy to collect it race-based data
yes on both ends so I think for some
people not
knowing what to do are not wanting to
deal with the consequences of
understanding what the racial
disparities are and then also
communities being concerned that it
would be used against them so on both
ends and so my position is aligned with
the Canadian Public Health Association
in which they had recommended the
culturally safe collection of race-based
data so that again it's not just about
how do we fix these communities but it's
like how do we address the factors in
society that that led to certain
communities being predisposed to to
having higher rate of Kovach 19
infections before a George Floyd was
killed this pandemic was infected with
racism Asian Canadians have been
targeted yelled at spat at and worse
people lashing out at them in the
mistaken belief that somehow their Asian
descent makes them responsible for the
novel coronavirus as Robin Gill reports
that is reopening old wounds on DC's
flower shop in Toronto's East End has
been in his family for 48 years passed
on to him from his parents he grew up in
the multi-ethnic neighborhood and had
never experienced racism then he noticed
his customers acting strangely when
Kovan 19 surfaced people started getting
a little bit more apprehensive about
coming inside after the whole Luhan
thing earlier in the year in the news
people started kind of questioning was
it safe to approach me anymore just
because of my Asian background he was
even asked if he had ever been to Wuhan
I've never been to China myself the
virus originated in Wuhan China and that
fact has fuelled attacks against Chinese
Canadians like Trixie Ling she was just
going for a walk when she was confronted
by a young white man who called her
names and then spit on her I actually
felt really angry that was probably the
strongest emotion I felt angry that
she'd been singled out in this
humiliating way based on her racial
background a lot of these racist
incident has increasingly
a lot of them is done by white folks and
so when it's that aggression and racism
against people of color there's this
other ring of you don't belong here the
Vancouver Police Department says there's
been a 600 percent increase in reports
of hate crimes targeting the Asian
community whether they're of Chinese
Korean or Japanese descent a woman
punched at a bus stop an older man
pushed out of a store Chinatown sprayed
with graffiti British Columbia's anti
racism Network doesn't think there's a
rise in hate crimes it's always been
there more people are just coming
forward we're in a time right now when
people are feeling more open about
expressing their feelings they're
exposing their racist ideas the anti
Asian sentiment also labeled the Yellow
Peril is entrenched in public health
emergencies going back to when the
Chinese first started immigrating to
Canada
Sandra Hyde is a Montreal professor
whose research focuses on the
correlation between pandemics and how
different cultures get targeted during
health scares in a pandemic where we
have no cure no vaccine people are
afraid and they want to place blame and
it's easy to place blame on somebody
else who's different than you the
Chinese were blamed for the 2003 SARS
crisis because it first appeared in
Guangdong a Pittsburgh paper felt
compelled to publish this controversial
political cartoon that in 2020 a major
Toronto newspaper took it a step further
and Canada's top doctor found herself in
the crosshairs of racist rhetoric by a
member of parliament does she work for
Canada or for China
it doesn't help when celebrities get in
on the action
take this racist branch posted on rocker
Bryan Adams Instagram it comes from
China then there's the influence of the
US president Donald Trump has been
deliberately disparaging calling it the
Chinese virus it's always an open season
and I think recently it's been easier to
be an open season because of the link
between Asia and the epidemic you know
coming coming from China people like
Trump calling it the Chinese virus or
the Wuhan virus without understanding
that you know viruses know no borders
Iran too was a hot spot for the new
coronavirus but the Iranian Canadian
community kept a lid on any attacks in
terms of an through runyan sentiments
there are and actions there are the
cases that I'm aware of but generally
speaking the community's not looking for
conflict and they just want to let it
slide and we're trying to encourage them
to come forward and speak out and feel
comfortable to you guys the outbreak of
racism is so palpable in BC that the
left-handed governor launched an anti
racism campaign but sadly our success
has been marred by a troubling increase
in race-based violence
different together is aimed at quelling
the hate but it's a challenge with the
overt anti Chinese language coming from
south of the border
it's a topic that people need to be
talking about and we need to be
normalizing the discussion about racism
what's happened in the United States
Donald Trump has normalized the the
ability to be racist and in Canada we
need to do things differently we need to
normalize this discussion anti racism
advocates believe it starts with
education in elementary schools and
should continue in the workplace you
have to make it mandatory just like
universities are now making workshops on
sexual misconduct mandatory I think you
don't set it up as if it's an option
Trixie Ling knows she's now going to be
a voice for change to end systemic
racism it's not just a one-off
individual thing is actually a
collective structural problem that we
have and Andy Hsu has a message for
anyone who wants to turn this pandemic
into a cultural war this virus has no
face it could happen to anyone
and we shouldn't be afraid of each other
to help guide us through some things to
combat this I'm joined by Professor
Carol liao she teaches law u BC with a
focus on business law ethics and
corporate governance
she's a second-generation Taiwanese
Canadian professional Yale thanks for
joining us you know we like to believe
in Canada that were enlightened and
tolerant and that racist acts are
isolated what is your sense of how
pervasive anti-asian racism is in Canada
you know well there's a false sense of
Canadian exceptionalism that forgets our
very racist history but we need to be
honest about colonialism the Chinese
head tax and exclusion act Japanese
internment ongoing anti black and anti
indigenous violence and over
incarceration you know we desperately
want to see our past is disconnected
from our present like we reach some sort
of self-determined Island and we don't
like to acknowledge a systemic racism
right it's much easier for people to be
disgusted with hate crimes you know of
course we're against that and to
compartmentalize acts of violence it's
isolated events until they finally come
to a head like they are in the US but
it's much harder for us to admit her own
racist tendencies both conscious and
unconscious you know I've lost count of
the number of people that have told me
that they are colorblind or don't see
race there's a lot of defensive nough
sand it's just not something I find
people are generally open to talking
about here even though there is
prevalent casual and systemic racism
Medicus so when it comes to this
pandemic in kovat 19 how does it compare
to anti-asian racism that was linked to
SARS 18 years ago is it worse now well
you know I don't have to even look back
to SARS to be reminded of anti Asian
sentiment you know in the past few years
as Vancouver's housing prices
have skyrocketed you know there's been a
lot of collateral racism I'll be having
coffee with a group and overhear someone
saying they don't want to sell to an
Asian person and I'm right there you
know and I had a man shouted h 'l slur
in my open car window as he drove by and
my three young children were behind me
and heard it all and that was
pre-pandemic so you know this anti asian
sentiment none of it is surprising to me
you know it was all predictable with
some politicians practically inviting it
and you know given the protracted period
of copán where the the end seems so far
away and with the widespread suffering
of so many people and this convenience
of misdirected blame on not just Asian
but any Asian looking person yes it is
worse there's overt racism we know and
there's unconscious bias you do training
sessions to help companies overcome
unconscious bias can you explain in
simple terms what that is I'm sure a
simple example is how we hear someone
with an English accent and think they
sound smart yet research has shown any
other accent and we judge more harshly
you know empirical studies also show
time and again how women and people of
color have to work harder to establish
competence in the workplace and prove it
over and over again so you know the
increased anti-asian racism it should
remind asian canadians that we've often
benefited from a system that's rooted in
anti blackness and how much the model
minority position it's only used to
bolster the status quo until it's taken
away and you know in Vancouver in
particular I hear people claim there
can't be that much anti black racism
here given how many black people they
perceive are in Vancouver you know and
I'd like to ask what is the right number
for people to recognize racism you know
I've also heard so many people
expressing surprise that there is
anti-asian racism given how many Asian
people there are it seems we're either
too few to matter or too many to matter
so what's the right number before we're
willing to recognize these things and
what are the obligations do you think of
business leaders and politicians not to
enable racism not
to be complicit in it well you know
representation matters take a look at
the makeup of your leadership the
numbers are abysmal in the corporate
sector less than six percent of board
seats are comprised of people of color
and less than 1% are held by indigenous
peoples you know organizations should
commit to anti-racist biased training
and it cannot be a one-off either
there must be education and deliberate
ongoing interventions from both an
individual and organizational level you
know they should amplify marginalized
voices they should have whistle
whistleblower protections and non
retribution policies demonstrable
inclusion practices each organization of
course has their own issues but there
needs to be some introspection on the
power dynamics within each institution
do you think this pandemic could be a
teachable moment about racism or could
it make it more pervasive you know it's
behold on all of us to recognize that we
where we're situated in all of this we
can't have public ambivalence you know
my heart's been just broken too many
times watching the uptick in overt
racism caused by very live issues in
this city and we need to think about
what we can do long term to address the
systemic racism within our communities
and hopefully now with everything that's
happening we can spend less time
discussing whether racism is real and
exists within our institutions and focus
more on what can be done about it
you know and change is the result of
concerted persistent and ongoing efforts
of many individuals that collectively
move us towards change and no time does
it change things deliberate actions do
when we're living history right now so
it's time for us to step up and listen
to those seeking change
still ahead staying close to home you're
talking about a group of no more than
four people summer vacation plans shrink
four Canadian families plus going to
waste
PPE pollution and the Canadians stepping
up to reverse the trend and a looming
debt crisis just not an affordable
option for us right now who the koban
nineteen recession is hitting the
hardest
[Music]
long before this pandemic alarm bells
were ringing about the amount of
household debt Canadians are carrying
now the financial stress for many is
through the roof
some aren't earning at all many earning
less and millions are getting emergency
benefits from the government what
happens when all that ends david akin is
exploring that for us a 1986 honda
goldwing
a machine built for the open road my
husband and I love to ride motorbikes in
the summertime but just been something
that we've clicked with right from the
beginning when we first met but there
will not be any long trips this summer I
know it's just not an affordable option
for us right now
in fact crystal Chalmers is fighting now
just to save her home we're really in a
rock and a hard place right now with the
pandemic crystal a host cleaner has not
been able to work since March
her husband's still working but on much
reduced hours
neither are eligible for benefits like
the Serb and while their bank has given
the Chalmers deferrals on the mortgage
payments they make on their mobile home
the owner of the lot has not given them
a break on the lot rent we're still
paying over $700 a month just for our
lot rents but now they're $2,500 in
arrears to the landlord and facing the
prospect of eviction bill collectors are
still calling even though you know
there's nothing we can do lot rent right
now even though we can defer our
mortgages and move on communities
we can't defer our lot rents and when
you don't pay your rent you can still
lose your home to pay the bills the
chalmers have had to add to their
household debt the credit card balance
is higher they board a hundred here or a
hundred there from friends and family so
even if they get through all this they
are going to find themselves with more
debt we don't have a plan we're just
trying to survive right now millions of
Canadians are fighting the same
financial currents forced to take on
more debt to make it through the
pandemic it starts with a health crisis
that triggers an economic crisis that
quite likely is going to trigger an
insolvency crisis and how we handle each
one of these things depends on how we
handle the previous crisis and even
before the pandemic hit experts were
sounding the alarm about rising debt
levels fueled by low interest rates in a
relatively strong economy Canadians have
been borrowing more and more for
everything from new home appliances to
new cars to home renovations 20 years
ago Canadians had about a hundred and
six dollars worth of debt
every $100 worth of disposable income
but over the last several years that
ratio of household debt to disposable
income has soared to one hundred and
seventy-six percent in other words one
hundred and seventy-six dollars of debt
for every $100 of disposable income and
that was before the pandemic you're
probably going to see it soar to
something like two hundred and thirty
percent and the reason is is that the
denominator income will will have fallen
because of the employment shock that
we're having during during the pandemic
and the lockdown so two hundred and
thirty dollars of debt for every one
hundred dollars in disposable income I
think we're probably going to end this
crisis with even more indebted
households the rate of household debt is
super important to understanding how
households can propel the economy
because they do fifty four seven percent
of the economy is run on the fuel of
household spending stuff so as they take
on more debt they're gonna be a little
bit more skittish about how much they
spend so far thanks largely to federal
income replacement programs like the
Serb personal bankruptcies and other
credit problems have not yet ticked up
yet I think what we're looking at
potentially is sort of what's being
termed the deferral cliff meaning that
government supports and payment
deferrals end while the economy hasn't
fully recovered or in some cases for for
personal consumers they haven't fully
recovered serb payments right now max
out at four months and mortgage
deferrals only buy a few months of
relief government supports and payment
deferrals for some of these debts are
giving Canadians to a certain degree of
false sense of security which is
actually allowing them to put off
dealing with the debts even though that
those debts may be just as bad if not
worse when this situation ends well
things get worse for consumers we'll
consider this Canada's big banks put
aside an extra 11 billion dollars in
loan loss provisions in the last quarter
alone the banks clearly believe that
some Canadians are not going to make it
through but the debt story in this the
Cova 19 recession has a unique twist
is absolutely clear is that women have
been hit harder than men in this
recession and that's the first time ever
in history because most recessions
usually men take it on the chin first
that's women like crystal Chalmers
working in the service industry in her
case cleaning homes and it's the service
industry that's been decimated in this
so-called qi session my children have
really struggled
I myself have really struggled if
crystal is forced to move her
neighborhood will lose a leader crystal
is president of her community League
because I'm a community leader I have
heard a lot of personal stories from
people in our community and the mental
health of people has been what's really
bothering everybody and her community
will lose a good neighbor the creator of
a giving cover for someone who might be
having trouble making ends meet and
they'll lose an artist and creator
Crystal's kids are old enough to be on
their own but for many women going back
to work cannot happen until there's a
solution for looking after the kids
schools have closed daycares have closed
they may be struggling with that
financial impact and having to look for
their care for their kids during home
during that period and that means policy
makers who want to ease a looming debt
crisis have to deal with the
responsibilities and stresses women face
a big one is child care there is no
recovery without a sheet cover E but
know she cover e with our child care and
we don't have a plan for either and
while government's ponder that issue
individuals who need cash to get through
the pandemic are urged to make plans and
seek advice do it now better to do it
now when people aren't seeking help as
much rather than waiting during a period
where maybe the demand spikes and then
you're you're going to have trouble
actually getting the help that you need
creak Banerjee is a personal finance
expert and he's with us from Toronto
great so many Canadians were carrying so
much household debt before this pandemic
now the financial stress is through the
roof
do you think we're approaching a
dangerous tipping point in Canada you
know I think we were dangerously close
to a tipping point before Koated 19
really hit if you take a look at
consumer insolvency filings they were
starting to trend up towards the end of
last year the big banks had already
started to assume people were going to
you know not make their debt obligations
so they started to set aside more money
for bad loans and again this was before
cove at 19 and because of Cobie 19
things have just gotten exponentially
worse so let's try to divide up some of
the problems would start with mortgages
more than 700 thousand Canadians have
applied for mortgage deferrals
but that's only buying time they still
owe the money of course if you're not
earning how do you deal with that yeah
it's a tough situation to be in and I
think what people really need to focus
in on is getting to that budget that
they've been procrastinating about for a
long time it really comes down to what's
coming in the door and what's going out
the door at the end of the day and if
you've had these severe income
interruptions you really need to pay
attention to what those expenses are and
create a short-term emergency budget
forecast what you would cut if you had
to make those cuts in the future so that
you reduce some of the uncertainty it
may not be good news but getting a grip
on your finances is more important now
than it's ever been so cutting back on
expenses saving if you can treat if
people aren't working now and they don't
qualify for emergency benefits from the
federal government can they do anything
to insulate themselves from the
financial crisis well that would be a
very dire situation to be in if you have
no income and you don't have any access
to any of the income supports which
means you'd have to look at some extreme
measures which would include looking at
all the things that you would
unfortunately have to sell in your
household and also looking to see what
kind of social assistance programs would
be available for you as well and I know
that a tough
idea to sort of stomach but again you
know tough times call for tough measures
you know the silver lining I guess if
there is one is that borrowing rates are
so low or is that really a silver lining
yeah it's good question I think part of
the problem is rates have been so low
for so long that that's part of the
reason that we got into these levels of
indebtedness what might be better is if
interest rates are a little bit higher
because right now if we think that
things are going to get economically
worse and there's gonna be more fallout
what steps can you know the Bank of
Canada take to try and stimulate
spending we're already at low interest
rates we can't go much lower so I don't
know if it's a silver lining and it's
also been part of the reason why we're
in this level of indebtedness in the
first place coming up you know it's
gonna be really difficult to replace the
new reality of domestic tourism we're
really focused on staying local this
summer where you can and cannot go for a
family vacation
[Music]
there's so much information surrounding
coronavirus out there now we know you
have questions email your questions at
Global News Don CA tune in to global
national or go to global une CA / : o
virus now to find the answers
summer vacations this year are going to
happen close to home for millions of
people travel to the US is still
restricted international travel may open
up at some point but with so much
uncertainty it's hard to make any plans
that means foreign tourists are going to
be staying home too
tourism is a big economic driver in
Canada from accommodation to
transportation 750,000 jobs depend
directly on tourism most of that
economic activity is generated
domestically by Canadians traveling to
places like parks campgrounds cottages
and attractions across the country as
might relay reports this could be the
year Canadians rediscover all the
wonders of home for kids it's the
official Senate of summer that last bell
of the school year before camps and
trips and well at the very least no
classes for a few months first ones here
but the summer of 2020 looks more like
this all our hopes and dreams dashed by
an empty parking lot in a closed
amusement park
[Music]
we're all Griswolds now interprovincial
travel is still banned in most of
Atlantic Canada in the Maritimes
so only Newfoundlanders are enjoying the
provinces famous iceberg watching season
and it's not even easy for locals the
iceberg tracker isn't updating the
location of the biggest Berg's this year
to avoid crowds forming and across the
Gulf and PEI and of green gables has
been silenced for the first time in 56
years Atlantic Canada's most famous
redhead may not have Cova 19 but fear of
the virus spreading has shut down the
Charlottetown festival so the bottom
line is there's still a lot of
uncertainty leading into the summer each
province has its own framework for
reopening but interpreting that
framework is up to the municipalities
and local health officials and it
doesn't always make sense so tours and
board officials are recommending if you
do travel make it hyper local so first
of all you know we're really focused on
staying local this summer and if you're
planning to go further afield than let's
say 50 kilometers then call where you
wanted to go and make sure that they are
open welcome to the original haunted
walk of Kingston for the past 20 years
haunted walks has introduced the curious
of the darker and ghostly sides of
Ottawa Toronto and Kingston they offer
walking tours outside where health
officials say it's safer which wasn't
enough to sway Toronto and Ottawa to
allow them to reopen only Kingston has
given them the green light but they
can't offer the regular 15 to 20 percent
tours we can have social distancing
between the tour guide and between a
small group but I'm talking about a
group of no more than four people so
very small the impact on tourism is
going to be massive it's an 80 billion
dollar a year industry that contributes
2% to Canada's GDP take away 30 billion
of that with no international visitors
and while the remaining 50 billion is
domestic that assumes Canadians will be
traveling from province to province only
Nova Scotia is open in Atlantic Canada
right now provided visitors quarantine
for 14 days the same rules that apply in
Manito
Quebec Ontario Saskatchewan Alberta and
BC are allowing visitors from other
provinces even though it's discouraged
tourism's big obvious is a big economic
driver but that's also hurts the culture
and fabric of our community in a way
that I think is you know it's gonna be
really difficult to replace me so what
are families to do day camps have been
allowed to open in most of the country
albeit with tough restrictions such as
limits on the number of campers and a
ban on transportation which Howie
Grossinger says applies to 80 percent of
the kids at camp Robin Hood in Markham
Ontario as a result grossing her and his
wife made the painful decision not to
reopen until next summer the outdoor
experience the pool the swimming the
instruction and quite frankly might like
social distancing and the camp
experience are just not compatible you
know you know we have four year olds two
six year olds a good population of those
75% of my day camp population are under
the age of eight it sounds bleak but
travel agent Lorraine Simpson says there
is some hope for adventure this summer
to go to Italy and also Portugal and
even Greece there's some amazing amazing
prices out there the hitch is that those
traveling abroad have to quarantine for
14 days upon returning but that could
change so you're rolling the dice flying
within Canada is an option too
and while there are incentives the deals
aren't as good still Simpson says people
are itching to get out of their homes a
very early test pilot style trip not
knowing anything and I just was
inundated with people saying yeah I'm in
no questions asked yeah I'm in so people
are ready to travel perhaps the most
intriguing summer idea involves camping
but since most campgrounds won't have
bathroom and showers open tents aren't
an option so that opens the door and the
highways to RVs 90 percent of Canada
dreams business in a normal year comes
from Europe but as we've come to know
2020 is anything but normal
domestic sales are
we up but nowhere near high enough to
make up for the international loss and
there's a lot of noise being made by RVs
that a lot of people are saying the RVs
are sold out the campsites are sold I
it's utter nonsense you know none of us
are sold out so the RV door is one
Canadians could walk through if they're
up for adventure that is next on the new
reality the costs of protection play
plastic play what we're doing to reduce
waste while keeping ourselves safe
[Music]
the term of PPE personal protective
equipment has been added to all of our
vocabularies it's not only essential for
health care workers it's now part of our
everyday lives or at least masks are and
many people are wearing disposable
gloves - problem is they're disposable
and they're ending up in our rivers and
oceans the pandemic has created a new
hazard to the environment Redman Shannon
takes a look at how we can do better the
biggest plane in the world lands in
Toronto carrying 130 tons of medical
supplies from China including personal
protective equipment PPE is crucial for
the safety of healthcare workers dealing
with Cova 19 but now all of us are
consumers - particularly for simpler or
non-medical face masks but also for
gloves the problem is not all of us are
disposing of them properly people across
the world are seeing more and more
discarded single-use PPE made from
polymers that don't decompose yet
another new source of plastic pollution
just as governments have begun tackling
the issue a group of French divers has
started digging fistfuls out of the
Mediterranean off the beautiful coke
desert divers Yoko Peltier says people
must remember trash on the ground often
gets washed into the sea similar scenes
are visible around the globe dr. Hillary
Nash is all too familiar with ocean
plastic just before the pandemic she
traveled from England to Panama to take
part in a sailing expedition to analyse
plastic pollution in the Pacific Ocean
and one afternoon in that day we have
another plastic gnash returned at the
start of the pandemic treating over 90
patience in an intensive care unit she
sees discarded single-use gloves and
face masks on her short walk to work a
potential health hazard and the types of
PPE many experts say aren't really
needed for the general public in health
care specifically for infection control
we always have even pre covert and my
message was always that so we can
continue to do that in health care and
protect people from infection we need to
be more mindful about the types of
plastics and the types of Cleveland
plastics that we using in other aspects
of our life
Toronto hospitals are cutting back and
waste - repurposing their respirators by
sterilizing them necessity the mother of
invention due to the strain on PPE
supply when it comes to clean hands the
public health agency of Canada says that
washing offers more protection than
wearing disposable gloves but even if
you need to wear it gloves
you still need to wash your hands anyway
or you can make a face covering out of
an old t-shirt health agencies around
the world offer tutorials on how to make
reusable washable face coverings so you
get a much better fit on the side
underneath came Troutman is an expert on
PPE standards and certification the
whole purpose of having people wear
masks at this point now if they're just
whether they be do-it-yourself masks or
the ones that we can still purchase are
for the purpose of us not spreading the
disease Troutman says homemade masks can
be better for non medics because you can
make them to fit your face and she
recommends using more breathable natural
fabrics like a high thread-count
bedsheet why natural materials tend to
be better is they have a rougher fiber
and that rougher fiber acts and can
catch more you know contaminants or
particles Troutman uses washable garden
gloves when shopping but insists you
need to be very careful when using any
gloves but again if you come out of any
usage with those gloves and touch any
surface you are now contam
the surface reusable masks could become
a part of everyday life now
so this Montreal fashion house decided
to cater to the market
we basically recycled all the ends of
rolls that we have of all the fabrics
that we've had from previous collections
the man has been really insane actually
we are trying to keep up with demand the
high-end fashion items sell for 50 bucks
but 10% of that goes to a local women's
shelter acknowledging the hidden trauma
of domestic violence in a pandemic
lockdown part of our so we're proud to
say that it's a hundred percent made
here
our martin materials are responsible and
they're easily washable than a reusable
a reminder that tackling the worldwide
problems of pandemic and pollution can
sometimes overlap with helping those
closer to home - we'll be right back on
the new reality
[Music]
and that is our program this week
here are some stories we're working on
for the new reality we've known about
the novel coronavirus for six months now
and it's still outsmarting us we have no
treatment and no cure
coming up we look at the many things
scientists still don't know about this
virus and the pandemic has reduced our
collective carbon footprint that's a
good thing but what does it mean in the
long term for climate change all those
stories coming up I'm Donna Friesen
thanks for watching
[Music]